bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique l'émission
consacrée aux coulisses de la
mondialisation un patronat patriotes on
pensait les grands patrons supporters du
libre échange et bien on les découvre
attachés à la souveraineté économique
depuis 2018 le principal syndicat
patronal français le medef accueille en
son sein un comité souveraineté pour en
parler je reçois son président laurent
giovachini également auteur d'un ouvrage
publié chez dunod intitulé les nouveaux
chemins de la croissance bonjour laurent
giovachini bonjour ali alors première
question très simple comment vous vous
voyez la souveraineté économique le sens
que nous donnons à ce concept de
souveraineté économique au au medef est
assez simple pour nos entreprises
françaises entreprises européennes la
souveraineté économique
c'est notre capacité à maîtriser notre
destin à faire en sorte en quelque sorte
que dans cinq ans dans dix ans il n'y
ait pas uniquement en france en europe
des filiales de groupe extra européens
et des salons de coiffure le comité
s'appelle exactement souveraineté et
sécurité des entreprises françaises
souveraineté et sécurité économique des
entreprises absolument c'est important
pour vous pourquoi attendre 2018 pour
que le medef le patronat français créé
ce comité je pensais que vous m'auriez
dit qu'au contraire nous avions été
plutôt précurseur parce qu'en 2018 il
faut se souvenir qu'il n'y avait pas eu
trois événements majeurs qui ont plutôt
contribué à remettre ces sujets de
souveraineté disons d'autonomie
stratégique au coeur du jeu il n'y avait
pas eu
tout juste l'élection de donald trump
2017 il n'y avait pas eu la crise
sanitaire ou 2020 il n'y avait pas eu
évidemment la guerre en ukraine 2022 et
il faut voir qu'en 2018 quand je crois
ou de bézieux a été élu à la présidence
du medef qu'il m'a confié la présidence
de ce comité nous étions peu nombreux
dans le débat économique y compris dans
le débat politique à prendre
véritablement en compte ces sujets
l'état l'avait
bien pris en compte je sais que le
président de la république peut après
son élection avait donné comme deuxième
priorité à ses services de
renseignements la priorité la protection
du patrimoine scientifique industrielle
technologique français juste après la
lutte contre le terrorisme mais nous
étions peu nombreux en europe parmi les
acteurs économiques à nous saisir de ça
et nous avons être précurseur par
rapport aux allemands par rapport aux
italiens que nous avons très vite
cherché à convaincre non je reste unie
vous voyez à quoi je fais référence le
retard par rapport aux rapports
historiques en france sur l'intelligence
économique qui date de 1994 et quatre
étarras porte du commissariat au plan et
on se fait pour ça que je parle de je
m'en souviendrai vernon quelle est votre
vision comment vous voyez aujourd'hui la
compétition internationale radicaliser
durci la compétition internationale elle
se caractérise par quoi depuis quelques
années déjà des tensions accrues entre
chine et états unis avec ce qu'on
appelait ya encore quelques années des
empires turbulent la turquie la russie
aujourd'hui la réussite un peu plus que
seulement turbulente et puis depuis
quelques temps et c'est favoriser par
l'agression de l'ukraine évidemment on
parle non seulement de tension de
rivalité mais de découplage quelques pas
je ne crois pas qu'il faille aller
jusqu'à dire que nous sommes entrés dans
une phase de démondialisation ce serait
exagéré mais qu'il y ait probablement
dans les années à venir une forme de
découplage entre les grandes zones
économiques et notamment à la faveur de
cette espèce de guerre froide dans
laquelle nous entrons progressivement
même assez rapidement je crois que c'est
une bonne description de la situation
actuelle et prévisible à moyen terme de
quoi on parle dans le comité où son
utilité on parle de tout on parle de
toutes les menaces et les risques qui
pèsent sur la sécurité et la
souveraineté de nos entreprises on parle
des risques en matière
d'approvisionnement on a vu avec la
crise sanitaire les problèmes de
médicaments les problèmes aussi de semi
conducteurs dès que l'économie a
commencé à redémarrer on s'est aperçu
qu'on dépend des uniquement de taïwan ou
presque uniquement on s'est aperçu
évidemment avec la guerre en ukraine que
le véritable or noir qu'elle est
substituée aux hydrocarbures au 21ème
siècle allait être les métaux
ra lithium cobalt nickel halliche sais
pas si vous le savez mais pour assurer
sa neutralité carbone en 2050 l'union
européenne va devoir consommer 35 fois
plus de lithium qu'aujourd'hui c'est
considérable et puis au delà des
problèmes de risques d'approvisionnement
on parle des cyber-menaces on parle de
lettres l'extraterritorialité de
certaines lois
du bas-rhin chinois et de ma chinoise ou
en parle aussi de prédation possible de
pépites européenne et française en
situation momentanément de difficulté
par des groupes extrêmes repères on
parle d'espionnage industriel donc c'est
très vaste et très transversal et c'est
quelque chose qui est très bien perçue
par nos adhérents au medef qui ont
compris que ce n'était pas un enjeu
réservé à des domaines particuliers
comme la défense historiquement c'est
dans ça concerne beaucoup de secteurs de
l'économie comment votre comité aurait
réagi aux rachats en 2014 de alstom
power par l'américain general electric
je crois qu'il faut sur ces sujets
considérés et nous sommes là pour ça au
medef qui lie à un bon équilibre à
trouver entre souveraineté et
attractivité entre autonomie stratégique
européenne française et ouverture au
marché on peut pas se couper d'un accès
aux technologies extra-européenne aux
investissements extra-européens donc
notre mission au medef c'est justement
dans notre dialogue avec les pouvoirs
publics qui quelquefois sont animés de
bonnes intentions mais vont trop loin
c'est de dire attention il ya une ligne
de crête sur laquelle nous devons
cheminer ensemble et à l'union
européenne d'un côté entreprises de
l'autre et leurs représentants medef bd
y en allemagne contre l'industriel
italie avec qui nous travaillons
étroitement ligne de crête sur lequel
dont nous ne devons pas dévié autonomie
stratégique et souveraineté oui mais pas
au prix d'un abandon et d'une espèce
d'autarcie qui n'aurait pas de sens par
exemple à faire carrefour tout devait
être racheté par un concurrent canadien
couche tard voilà on est quoi alors ses
études sa mesure de vous poser cette
question parce que on a pas mal débattue
dans le secret de nos instances au medef
de cette question les avis étaient pas
unanime vous savez en matière
d'investissements étrangers en france la
réglementation a évolué au fil du temps
au début quand j'ai commencé ma carrière
j'étais ingénieur
de l'armement et donc il y avait que la
défense qui était protégé entre
guillemets par ce dispositif
et puis après il ya eu le monsieur de
villepin qui a élargi un petit peu un
qu'après monsieur montebourg à élargir
et puis la loi pacte récemment a élargit
encore le neuilly compris aux secteurs
comme la sécurité alimentaire du
carrefour couchepin on peut et on peut
penser c'était l'opinion de certains cre
on n'est quand même pas dans un domaine
de souveraineté absolue on peut aussi se
dire que carrefour a une position de
place ma france et de d'employeurs
massif qui fait que soit sa prise de
contrôle par un un acteur
extra-européens n'était pas anodine
d'accord vous est aussi directeur
général adjoint de sopra steria qui est
une grande entreprise européenne
spécialisée dans le numérique je suppose
que la souveraineté de nos données
personnelles ça vous touche oui la
souveraineté de nos données personnelles
de nos industriels professionnels de nos
données sensibles ou savait par exemple
qu'après le 1er gp dès le fameux
règlement général sur la protection des
données qu'on a fait en europe j'allais
dire sans penser à mal vraiment pour
protéger les données personnelles et qui
est devenu une espèce de normes de fait
à porter quasiment extraterritoriale
aujourd'hui on a récemment en france
réformer un dispositif qui s'appelle la
loi de blocage qui consiste à permettre
aux entreprises de ne pas transmettre
les de leurs données les plus sensibles
en a fait un guide pour sa medef afep en
liaison avec
quelques interne notamment de la justice
américaine dix qui permet de protéger
les données sensibles et donner mon
professionnelle en tant que directeur
général adjoint de sopra steria moi ce
qui m'importe c'est effectivement
d'incarner le plus possible cette
souveraineté numérique trois niveaux
d'ambition dans ce domaine premier
niveau la cybersécurité la cyberdéfense
ça c'est le socle et on n'est pas si mal
que ça en france en matière de
cybersécurité de cyberdéfense super
collaboration public privé on l'a vu
avec l'inauguration récente du campus
cyber à la défense des grands groupes
l'état l'ansi des pme des start up on
n'est pas si mal deuxième niveau c'est
tout ce qui concerne la protection de
nos données au sens
exploitation valorisation de la donne
est là en europe on est un peu dans les
mains gap a déboîté x dont donc parler
de la fin du week-end béatrice chinoise
par
baidu et alibaba tel syndrome x et c'est
ce qu'on appelle en gros les hypers
skyler ou lenny gatekeeper ça dépend du
contexte en bon français tout ça bien
sûr et est donc c'est c'est par la
régulation qu'on arrive à limiter leur
puissance par exemple aujourd'hui avec
le digital services acquis tout texte
récent mais mais mais on n'est pas
uniquement défensif on a aussi des
acteurs européens comme ovh cloud comme
dassault systèmes à wasquehal etc et
puis le troisième niveau d'ambition en
souveraineté numérique c'est où est ce
qu'on peut vraiment créer des champions
européens capables de rivaliser
mondialement parce qu'il faut pas
forcément uniquement regardez les
endroits où les batailles ont été perdus
un peu perdu au moins provisoirement
mais il faut aussi regarder les domaines
où les places sont encore à prendre oui
tout ce qui est industries du futur
industrie 4.0 là on a un tissu
industriel en allemagne en france en
italie du nord etc qui n'a rien à envier
au tissu industriel américain ou chinois
et on aura pas d' excuses si on n arrive
pas à créer dans les cinq ou dix
prochaines années des acteurs majeurs
dans le domaine de l'industrie du futur
et c'est pas sans lien avec notre grande
volonté de réindustrialiser la france l
europe parce que c'est
l'industrialisation pour qu'elle soit
acceptée le vrai qu'elle soit verte
beaucoup d'ingéniérie environnementale
mais vous faudra aussi qu'elle soit
compétitive pour gommer le différentiel
de compétitivité avec l'asie du sud est
par exemple et pour ça il faudra
beaucoup de numérique beaucoup de
robotisation donc on a un terrain de jeu
formidable dernières questions réponses
rapides évidemment vous travaillez avec
les italiens les allemands et plus
largement avec d'autres syndicat
patronal absolument on travaille avec le
bd y amenant le medef allemand le medef
italien confindustria ce n'était pas
évident au début de les convaincre de
parler d'autonomie stratégiques
européennes ils nous voyaient un peu
venir avec nos gros sabots de français
attachés à ce concept et puis les wake
up call les réveils dont je parlais tout
à l'heure
je fais de les convaincre et maintenant
on est bien aligné et je dirais que
grâce à cet alignement ils ont pu aussi
faire amicalement pression sur leur
propre gouvernement huang tous à sa
ligne dans une vision européenne qui est
de plus en plus cohérente et et
puissante merci beaucoup laurent jura
qui ni pour vos réponses l'entretien de
l'intelligence économique et termine
évidemment vous pouvez retrouver cette
émission sur france 24 points comme sur
nos réseaux sociaux et aussi sur nos
podcasts au revoir
[Musique]